hi everyone I'm Ilana or charl on his
own and I just finished playing forza
horizon 2 here at Gamescom now I am the
first one but I didn't actually get
around to playing it so I didn't really
know what to expect but from what I can
tell Forza horizon 2 is an updated more
social version of the original Forza
horizon and from what I played I really
enjoyed it so for the horizon 2 takes
place during the horizon festival which
is apparently in southern Europe and it
focuses on southern France and northern
Italy and there are going to be over 200
cars featured in the game
there are now also dynamic weather
patterns which is the biggest thing that
stood out to me in this game so I played
one race and I saw most other people
that I saw playing it all played the
exact same race and I even so Phil
Spencer who's the head of Xbox played
and he got 12 pretty much everyone got
12 and it's because you do the race and
then it starts raining at a point and
it's like something about the physics in
this game is so much more realistic than
every other racing game that it throws
everyone off so they do really well
until it starts raining and they just
can't handle that that total shift I
don't ninth in my game I was winning up
until it started raining and it's just
that I think a lot of games are way way
too easy with with whether they're also
going to be comi similar to an IRL calm
each basically you'll be able to go hang
out with other people and check out that
cause it's super social you can start
your own drift club or take a road trip
with everyone else you can have 1000
people in your club
but it also has dr itas which is similar
to Forza Motorsport 5 drivatar basically
replaced every single driver in Forza
horizon 2 but because it's open while
they can't exactly replicate things like
they do in Forza Motorsport 5 like how
exactly you break into a corner so it's
going to track more stuff like how fast
a person goes or how aggressive there is
a driver or maybe how precise they are
instead so none of that stuff is
scripted or planned meaning that you
know every race no car is going to do
the exact same thing because they're
actually based off of other people's
driving styles
but of course and I don't even know if I
really need to mention this it's also
extremely pretty the game is going to be
releasing on the xbox 360 and the xbox
one on the thirtieth of September 2014
that is it for this video I hope you
guys enjoyed it and don't forget that I
am still giving away an xbox one on my
Facebook page the link to that is below
if you would like some more details I'll
see you guys next time